have an update NASA has said that there
will be a hardware random number
generator on the rover that we have
access to and after that they made one
more comment they reminded me that we
just need our algorithm to work in
practice for something to work in
practice it means that there's always
some possibility of error but perhaps
the possibility is so small that we
ignore it in practice and if this sounds
crazy just realize that in the physical
world nothing is ever certain there's
always chances for error
for example chip packaging contains
small amounts of radioactive
contaminants and when these decay they
release alpha particles which can
actually flip bits in memory and perhaps
change a number unexpectedly and even
more interesting cosmic rays can also
cause soft errors we can never remove
the chance of error
completely and I asked NASA exactly well
what error probability is acceptable and
they said we just need to make sure that
the probability of air for a given trial
is less than the odds of hitting the
lottery twice in a row and the odds of
hitting the lottery say 649 twice in a
row is 6 times 10 to the negative 14 so
let's just be safe and round down and
say our error probability is 10 to the
minus 15 safe enough
we will not expect to see an error and
it could run hundreds or thousands of
times now my question is would access to
randomness help us speed up a decision
algorithm such as this prime allottee
test and this is a deep question so
let's step back and look at the big
picture given some collection of
integers from 1 to some limit n say
let's think of it as our universe of
integers we can always divide a
collection into two sets and a decision
problem can actually be thought of as a
partition into two sets for example
provided some N is n less than 100 it
will output yes for
all integers less than 100 so here is
one collection and no for all others
which is another collection okay so
let's now focus on recognizing Prime's
with a decision and ideally what we
would like is some simply computed
criteria that all Prime's satisfy and no
composites satisfy
now if we knew some simple pattern which
describes the location of all primes and
only primes then given some number n we
could simply check event follows that
pattern but the problem is that so far
no exhaustive and simply computed
pattern has been found for all primes
and no composites or all composites and
no primes
but we do know fast tests for most
composite numbers so for example a
simply computed criteria would be a test
for evenness and all even numbers are
divisible by two and it's fast because
we can tell if something's even by just
looking at the last digit and even as n
grows the problem doesn't get any harder
we just look at that last digit also
known as the low order bit now realize
that we can use this evenness test as a
low-quality composite test in that we
could have some algorithm except a
integer n and all our algorithm does is
check if it's even if it is even and
greater than two then we know with 100%
certainty it is composite because we
have proof think of two as our composite
witness however if not then we aren't
exactly sure if it's odd it could be
prime since all Prime's are odd or it
could be one of the many composites
which are odds such as nine or 15 and
this massive region of odd composites
makes for an unacceptable test now to be
clear let's draw this provided some n n
can be either prime or composite if n is
prime our algorithm will say prime 100%
of the time since no Prime's are even
that are greater than two and it will
never say composite when a prime is
provided however if n is composite our
algorithm will say composite about 50%
of the time and prime 50% of the time so
this means that if our algorithm outputs
composite it means it found proof or
composite witness
however if our algorithm outputs Prime
we know there is an unacceptably large
chance of air
until now our strategy has dealt with
this large unacceptably large error by
iteration and let's draw the flow of our
machine given some n our machine does a
series of divisibility tests starting at
a is 2 it asks does a divide n and if it
doesn't divide n then we can eliminate
all of this region then it asks the next
question does n divide 3 and if not then
we eliminate that whole section and as n
divide 5 7 and so on and notice these
are disjoint sets which gradually fill
up all possible composites now if we
ever ant answer yes along the way then
we have proof that n is composite and a
whatever it is at that point is our
witness
so we halt in and output composite from
our algorithm otherwise we continue
trying until we exhaust all possible
composites until we hit the square root
of n since we know remember every
composite number n must have a factor
less than or equal to the square root of
n so this really leads to the final
question in our algorithm if no
witnesses are found and a is greater
than the square root of n then we
suddenly have proof and we halt note put
Prime
so realize we have to exit paths through
our algorithm both paths represent proof
of certainty that n is either prime or
composite and when n is prime we try all
possible divisors and we basically rule
them all out and that is our proof that
on its prime the problem with this
strategy is that our test value a at
minimum requires us to cycle through
every prime starting from 2 to the
square root of n so as n grows the
number of primes grow with it that
results in too many iterations in the
worst case such as when we provide a
prime to our algorithm looking at the
big picture now realize it's providing
proof when n is prime which we now know
we don't exactly need no one said we
needed to prove it
we just needed to be 99.9999 fifteen
nines percent certain hmm so we actually
need to think about the composite test
that's being used in our algorithm
remember our fastest trial division
primality tests thus far have tried to
use prime patterns such as 6k or all
Prime's are of the form 6k plus or minus
1 to help walk along the Prime's only
and eliminate many of the composites to
save time and remember a test like this
can be turned into a composite test that
is given some integer n is of the form
6k plus or minus 1 and we could say it's
probably prime but there are many
composites still which follow this
pattern
it doesn't include Prime's only just all
Prime's and some composites and we can
think of these extra composites as a
leak and this leak is our source of
error now if we invert it and ask is and
not of the form 6-k plus or minus 1 then
we can say with 100% certainty it is
composite so the leak is our source of
air on the prime side but in this case
it's unacceptable it's not a
non-negligible air there's a much larger
probability we need to define a new comp
a testing procedure which is able to
shrink this space and make the chance of
air negligible which means we'll need to
review how we can actually shrink heirs
with iterations I think we should now
post their ideas below regarding no not
what kind of tests might we want to
perform and also more importantly how
could a random generator random number
generator really help us